якщо відкривши свою ринг йде біля вар
україни лужні дні поза манув уроку
результати виявилося з укороченими
за ногу боку падіння українського
експорту замшу зростанням експерти
проаналізували до низу 2015 топ топ
йорж повний рик після супроводу
другові хворих преференцій для України
ще брат і номінальною зіпсуйте
виражаються доларах то падіння склад 2-3
адже сотки на персеполь це не травня по
зад і онуків play with його відкриття
європейських ринку у team нас правді ціни
так я не кричу тимсі самого 2015 уроки
ціни на сиру на душі синів підлоги
a supple його на метали сир на саміті
дві позиції стає у нас 40500 кіу
всього українського експорту
теж ми прибрав йти новий чин ник і
реальний експорт дуже вона багата наша
на 2 адже соткою alesis
знайди зара відстань сільській
державі це корчові та промислів вас
тебе скоро чине
на жаль щоб поза тим tailor denim ви
ворушитися пов'язана з конфліктом на
сході України через бою ідеї
катастрофічно впала в рівні на
тому місці на заході України активно
розвивається в рівний з комплектуючих
для автомобілів
туристу та тип досвідом українське а йти
продукція ви ж сильні позиції україни
увійти в сектор США за рахунок аутсорсингу
вона і без середніх у рибниці програм
c буду один з головних напрямків
експорту дуй з розум з гарного йому
продуктом та а також транспортним
сектором з посиланням на зайти україни
як транзитна держава експорту Росії
манула ворогів пообіцяєш на 52 сотки в
європейський ринок не компенсується їх
витрат теж експерти народити і назвали коти
за нашим ринком і пройдусь ним одеським
то африканським україномихом і повернули
прикинься з пари важливо сиру війною
україни на хмару обрамляю готові
продукцію економісти проспективного 7 см
та новини україни для виходу на ринки з
і для розмов пам'ятних результатів просить
почитати та 35 роки
ще українською це європейські
брати бізнесмени на логотипі